Salut les naturalistes !
Ces images ont ététournées dès notre arrivée dans la maison, en2012.
Vous connaîtrez peut-être la salamandretachetée,
le triton marbré, le triton palmé etle crapaud commun.
Ces quatre espèces sont
dépendantes de l'eau pour se reproduire
et c'est initialement pour elles que j'ai décidé
decreuser la mare qui est à côté de moi.
Depuis, d'autres animaux ont été attirés par
ce pointd'eau et c'est clairement l'endroit du jardin
où je passe le plus de temps à observer lafaune
et je ne suis pas prêt d'en avoir marre.
Ça, c'était le 18 avril 2015 :
le jour oùnous avons creusé la mare.
Une journée présentée d'ailleurs en détails dans mon film
"Jardin sauvage".
Depuis, la biodiversité s'estinstallée d'elle-même
et c'est un écosystème àpart entière qui s'est créé.
Certains animaux interagissent avec la mare de manière très
ponctuelle.
C'est le cas des hérissons ou desoiseaux qui viennent juste y boire,
comme cettegrive musicienne par exemple.
Mais d'autresespèces, à l'inverse, vont passer
la totalité deleur existence dans l'eau
depuis le stade del'œuf jusqu'à celui de larve puis d'adultes.
C'est notamment le cas de plusieurs insectes.
Il y a la notonecte par exemple, une sorte de punaise aquatique
quise reconnaît facilement car elle nage sur le dos.
D'ailleurs, en grec ancien "noto" signifie
le dos et "nectos" veut dire la nage.
Ily a aussi les dytiques, une grande famille
d'insectes qui appartiennent au même ordre
queles scarabées ou les coccinelles par exemple.
Ils sont capables de voler pour passer d'unemare à l'autre
mais leur corps est clairementtaillé pour la nage.
Certaines de leurs pattessont d'ailleurs devenues de véritables pagaies.
Dans la mare, il y a aussi des animaux
qui vont passer seulement une partie
de leur existence dans l'eau. Ils vont
ensuite quitter le milieu aquatique pour
se reproduire et chez les insectes vous
en connaissez tous au moins un : la libellule.
Avant de devenir des acrobates
des airs, les libellules mènent unevie
de redoutables prédateurs sous l'eau.
Et leurs larves ressemblent plutôt à ça
ou à ça.
Avant d'aller plus loin, juste une petite précisioncar beaucoup de personnes
appellent libellules des insectes qui parfois n'en sont pas.
Ici, une vraielibellule avec deux gros yeux qui se touchent et
des ailes bien ouvertes lorsque l'insecte estposé.
Ici, par contre nous avons affaire à unedemoiselle.
Ce sont des insectes en apparencesimilaire à
une libellule mais leurs yeux nese touchent pas
et leurs ailes sont repliés sur
le dos lorsqu'ils se posent.
Toutes les espècesde libellules et de demoiselles
vont connaîtreune incroyable métamorphose
qui leur permetde passer d'une larve aquatique à un adulte
capable de voler.
Et en accéléré, ça donne ça.
Notre tour d'horizon des petites bêtes de la mare
serait incomplet sans évoquer un autre groupe
d'animaux dont le cycle de vie est indissociablede l'eau : les amphibiens.
Anciennement appeléebatraciens, cette classe de vertébrés regroupe
les tritons, les salamandres, les crapauds et lesgrenouilles.
Toutes ces espèces vont mener une vieaquatique
à l'état de larve que l'on connaît sous le terme de têtard,
puis une vie terrestreune fois adulte.
D'ailleurs, l'étymologie dumot amphibien vient du grec ancien
amphibios qui veut dire tout simplement "double vie".
Tous les amphibiens de France sont
des espèces protégées par la loi
ycompris les espèces plus communes comme
lecrapaud commun ou ici la grenouille verte.
Quatre ans après la création de la mare,
une nouvelle espèce d'amphibien a fait
son apparition dans notre plan d'eau:
le triton alpestre.
Ce jour-là, j'étais comme un fou.
Cela signifie donc que les amphibiens,
aumême titre que certains insectes, sont capables
d'étendre leur territoire en colonisant denouveaux
sites de reproduction y compris dans un jardin.
C'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
Je vous donne rendez-vous au prochain épisode !